las palmas aux canaries
c'est le point de départ de cette
expédition dans quelques jours six
hommes et sept femmes vont embarquer à
bord de ce radeau la kali destination le
mexique le but de laventure étudier le
comportement humain dans des situations
difficiles tenter d'analyser l'origine
de l'agressivité le promoteur de ce
voyage expérimental un homme un mexicain
nommé santiago chine au bel âge et la
bonne fortune d'être kidnappée par un
avion
je suis été amenés à cuba je crois que
je me suis laissé l ombre des sciences
qui s'occupe des problèmes d' agressions
des violences des frictions qui était
vraiment kidnappé et j'ai sorti des
données que j'ai déjà publié quelques
semaines je vois assez intéressante dans
les circonstances des crises ainsi
qu'aux instances un petit peu difficile
les comportements humaine ça devient onu
c'est là-bas où on apprendre alors
maintenant mais kidnappé moi même si
vous voulez avec les autres je crois que
ça c'est les compléments naturels à sa
canne et qui en dépendent de vic
humanité je crois que le symbolisme et
nous vivons avec des symboles tout le
temps des l'arabe
juillet le mexican paresseux et la
suédoise diligent et les vietnamiennes
l'american blanc l'américaine noir on a
besoin de ça on peut le répéter tant de
fois que vous voudrez je crois qu'on a
besoin de dessin est ce que vous
attendiez également beaucoup du
comportement sexuel de l'équipage
ça c'est une question qui remet pause si
souvent que je pense que je vais faire
après une petite étude d pourquoi ce qui
me demande ça et pourquoi pas plus hier
p -o mais demandent plus et dates des
autres laquelle ils ne mesurent que 12
mètres sur 7
il est construit d'acier de polyester
c'est dans cet enfer que pendant plus de
trois mois
treize personnes vont vivre 24 heures
sur 24 ensemble sans pouvoir fuir
c'est dans cette pièce de 9 mètres
carrés qui n'autorise que le déplacement
à quatre pattes que l'équipage devra se
loger et si vous a séduit
on peut traverser l'atlantique sur un
radeau déjà bon c'est extraordinaire
puis aprilia l'expérience humaine il ya
yaffa tout ce que ça comporte tout le
monde peut s'imaginer ce que c'est mais
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
expérience humaine beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses pour moi même
beaucoup de choses pour les autres puis
je ne sais pas je vais pas vous dire ce
que je vais il a rencontré le caylar y
avait prouvé
oui vous les enfants 2 qu'elle a
aujourd'hui une fille de 14 ans un
garçon de 11 ans que ce qu'on pense 12
enfants
ils sont heureux ils sont très très
heureux et trouve ça formidable une
autre marque aussi le jeune pop vouloir
partir que nous avons pour moi pas du
tout non je crois que une chose comme ça
ça n'arrive jamais ou alors une fois
dans la vie par chance et on passe au
dessus de tous les petits inconvénients
qu'on peut trouver
est ce que la vie à bord de ce radeau ne
vous semble pas a priori difficile enfin
les conditions de vie qui pompent être
imposée à l'équipage moyens et beaucoup
de choses difficiles dans la ville
savait prendre le métro tous les matins
je sais très difficile et on s'y habitue
on le fait je crois qu on s'habituera à
vivre évidemment y voyant des
difficultés défections mais on en
rencontre tous les jours des difficultés
puissent tout ça ça change c'est
chouette